how are we really doing artillery battle
against no no God no tanks here's one
see what tanks are like hell yeah it's
like artillery on wheels I gotta go the
bathroom first I'll be right back real
quick wait I can't join the server it's
burning a game already mark this is
amazing it's gonna be so good that would
be great
I would love to mark all right join the
server quick I'd love to quick join it
Oh God Oh help me Oh Oh
okay so you guys have already figured
out how this thing operates oh yeah we
played it for 30 seconds oh wow okay we
know the left joystick support and right
joystick rather is important either the
left or the right joystick is important
one of them or are you huge bang all
right so I'm going up a mountain oh wow
oh my god this is so funny well I see
dust on the horizon guessing that's one
of you guys oh well my hand broke okay
guess I'm not driving don't worry if you
drive if you drive around a little bit
your hand might come back okay I see
wonderful hey what's up nerd who's doing
donuts in the desert
who's this douchebag oh here we go let's
fly it out Oh how'd you do that
oh look you over but you broke my hand
so you did good still I'm just
permanently in Reverse I'm coming for
you what's waiting to push it when you
push it you're gonna push your joystick
to pull I don't know it doesn't right
for me and I gotta adjust my aim here a
little bit okay wish I could stop moving
Oh would you do something like that I'm
playing bump okay mark is this you that
I'm hey what's up buddy
[Laughter]
while at the target
where you going where are you going I
literally couldn't get married the
target what the hell miss you Scott damn
it I forgot what you the target
oh my god I've got both my hands like
you guys are so dead wait yeah because I
have skills and stratagems Christ sorry
I'm sorry
frames gonna play a different game now I
think no no no no no no no no frames I
think I just need to learn how to better
grab the balls you know what I mean so
Bob team up on Wade yeah sure okay so
good please you guys you need to sing
the chance I can't turn left this match
though so okay good just don't leave me
to the right you know coming on the
horizon just descend it's gonna go for a
little bit of a stroll oh Jesus that's
really close
hang on oh god I'm not like no we're
yeah we're yeah yeah
the target ball right if you get both
hands locked on this game mode is
actually really fantastic yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yes kill me I want to spectate
come on man you got to be a part of this
[Music]
there's a new grenade toss no I got find
out a way to cheat at this game and then
you'll be fine mark don't team up on me
you'll miss me I'm your buddy let's get
mark I can't turn left again so uh I
dumped my hands I swear to God are
intentionally doing the opposite of
that's not good I gotta be right back
okay figuring [ __ ] that way yeah what
you got to do way to just don't turn
your wrist don't do nothing just place
it on the ball and click yeah yeah
that's crap and not working not to go
left go left this time hold on holy
smokes all right hold on what do you
mean you can't go just pull it and go
all right I I know how [ __ ] new
steering works I don't get why it's not
working
that's all there is to this I can't
click now my buttons I can't grab wait
well hold on one finger I got one finger
that's working please why do the other
buttons not work
and that wasn't you oh god it wasn't you
where are you oh okay wait wait wait
what is the problem here why is are you
looking at my right hand doesn't want to
like what no matter what I click and I
got it it doesn't grab anymore
what see how my fingers don't grab well
then use a s DWF this one works I am
this is the only working finger I just
got to be left-handed yeah tell ya what
see all right it's a new day working on
the ball I can grab it
alright words one forwards stoppin we're
yanking we're breaking we're banking
someday you'll respond to me
alright well who needs to shoot when
you've got driving for you just see wait
for I get this bad boy gear
I don't like turning left no you're
lying to me excuses I'm doing everything
I can to push this ball left
I like this mountain a lot though so
where's gonna left yes left oh you sweet
succulent baby not the words I wanted to
use I have full control of my tank
already
where are you dumbasses Titanic I'm
trailing wave locked on target
did you say your by the Titanic you're
on the other side Oh baby I'm right next
to you you can turn left did you know
Justin seemed to be turning left at the
moment no no kind of straight like what
you guys oh my god it turned left to
miss you if I'm honest what's up how's
it going
oh good pull you out of your misery
waving Marc house this house it has the
race looking from a servo cinematic
shots wait you just put them on the
balls and you grab that's it I know
you'd think it would be easy I just
gonna sit back and watch
wait if you can shoot Bob if you can
manage to you can do it Bob try and sit
still we will film drown man part 4 we
will do that if you can shoot it if you
can't just I don't know if he's trying
to make it effort I'm not sure these
balls you want me to park in front of
you see you keep your turning why are
you my hand is not on that wheel okay
I'm gonna try and keep myself my let it
go God you just ran me over
just stay still on this hill wait there
you go wait now now's your chance this
would be anger live or die is the way so
I just give him all this is inches of
what
I didn't do anything I was literally not
doing anything
wait get Matt wait make me kill him I
was literally only controlling the hand
that something more on the motion stick
oh wow wait you're really bad at this
you are so incredibly bad at this that
somehow you just made me kill you in a
way that doesn't even make sense I've
got both balls firmly grasp okay I will
push the button wait if I come upon you
I will not engage oh my god what are we
are we in a truce marker which are just
exploring right now or oh I explored in
death mode I don't think as much to
explore I think it's time to throw down
it's gotta leave the target whose turn
oh you will not oh yeah baby here you're
off all missed you by inches missed you
by inches what do you think you're going
all right oh my god balls all right mark
I give you credit you figured this game
out you're the master thank you wait you
really you really struggle with this one
but no no no I figured I got it all
right you want another you know the
trick is my game breaks after the ready
button so I have to grab everything
before the ready buttons clicked
look I don't know whoops why would I do
that to myself wait wait
whoever that is wait hey God hang on I
was Wade competing now I don't know
someone shot towards me and I was not
dying 99 yeah don't you do Brad leave
the target to target yes yes oh I'm
sorry I had you in my sights
my mind hit you I don't understand how
are you not dead you again okay believe
what killing me I think what Lord you
and I both just hit each other directly
like several I think our shells hit in
midair so skills game is definitely not
broken working to me Anna wait you got
to lead the target no I did I just led
to Munn and Wade some day you'll get a
kill some day shouldn't have done that
that was so mean I'm sorry I feel bad
you'll never find me mark oh yeah I'm
going to hide away done
[Music]
no you don't Oh
oh my god
how far away I was miles away I did not
expect to hit you that was insane
skill uh I claim skill wait I believe
any of this stuff
oh me too oh wait no getting antsy in it
who is this is this you Bob I'll bet it
is are you chasing me around the boat
no what is that Wade it's maybe you're
facing what oh wait okay oh wait oh wait
I see you found your big boy pants oh
god you'd think that killed me don't you
we go I hear it okay oh god oh god oh no
you don't know you don't know you don't
know you know hey money
you just gotta know you killed me
accidentally that was bull all right
Wade
all right Wade
[Applause]
what a legend we went from the possibly
the worst that's ever played to killing
the best yeah this game is very
difficult this is possibly one of the
best and simulators I think we've ever
played yeah
even we can do it yeah yeah I like I'd
just make sure I'm ready before the
buttons so what happens if I do this Oh
God just curious is he god now yeah
where's your God now whit what happens
to you I don't even remotely believe you
okay
it waits over here go dude sir
see the trail the tracks in perfect
circle we like I got my hands on it
before they're just not in good standing
Oh God but if I switch it's bad I don't
get nothing happens when the ready
button goes I destroy you like no oh and
we're fighting oh we're fighting now I'm
just gonna watch mark king how many
shots look Nikita oh come on now that's
rude yeah I'm watching yeah you're going
after him get it mark you keep watch
wait like the United Nations I'm just
here to observe and well I'm not gonna
participate godom just prove that that's
not how it works that you totally got a
handle on your balls that was very
different it's very different I don't
believe you at all watch this look easy
cruising cruising oh you can fire with
your with your driving hand if you you
won't get too far to the left and like
catch the other joystick the perfect
strategy
oh you can't oh boy I don't kill like
that's good oh that's so close I'm just
trying to yank it that's all whoa whoa
your corpse now baby it's not very rude
don't be rude now a parent discipline
yeah you know a parent's shoot their
children with it like how wait always
gets the spot on the top of the hill in
the middle super this is whoa easy there
champ
oh wow okay kids no no you got you got
oh how did that miss oh yes coming down
to this point our guns at each other's
dicks and then run full speed at each
other see what happened let me restart
it for you guys I'm retired
I'm good I think I've settled oh man
that's fun this is the most fun I've
ever had with an simulator this weird
way I don't know it the last hero
Vikings
what about karting literally just
go-karts could be fun Oh what it's not
what I was expecting
oh that's awfully bold of you to assume
that I was ready oh wait there's like a
there's like a little thing down to your
left the game was it oh Jesus
Oh God God there is no in-between with
this steering there is no God
Oh God how do you go back the link on
the left thing and pull it back it's
like a boat throttle oh my god it's so
fast oh god it's so fast
now we're getting it now we're getting
it yeah uh-huh my arms oh okay oh is
this a jump or a ramp or what is the
deal here ho ho there goes my hair
and it was a ramp like I was deafening
oh I'm like half row no no I didn't find
half throttle it's either go or not go
Oh God in heaven through the air really
getting a good oh that's not good oh I
think I'm know if it's on I thought the
car was off but it's on Oh the game's
not on screen no mark can we restart
this yeah
please God holy crap all right let's go
a baby let's go baby fill this speed
wait Wow why am I going to reverse to
start a mark this is nice and easy how
are you doing that oh you didn't touch
it
ah I figured out the throttle this is
nice it's not I got it uh-uh
look at me oh oh wait no picking up feet
wings oh okay oh god wait no baby please
oh this is fast I didn't figure out the
throttle guys pull back your arm can we
restart no no no okay all right yeah
maybe what would be a no wait I'm doing
it
oh it's picks it picks up speed whether
you wanted to or not oh my goodness rims
oh good okay cool
all right I'll Boop the button are you
moving it mark wait wait wait my
throttle is doing some crazy things
crazy I think you really got to manage
the throttle Oh what have you was just
inside of me and I don't like it oh yeah
yeah yeah it's fine
oh okay oh it's fine it's fine it's fine
I'm correcting Oh God okay I'm just
wrong with onions really hard to manage
your throttle and manage the steering
wheel it is it is quite dull oh you just
can't grab this throttle why can you not
grab it if you're not ready
you really can't like keep your hand on
it I don't know
rattle rattle why would it just go
through Olga there I grifting for
control drift okay excuses oh yeah go
forward okay and we're back
don't you faster God do this broad block
oh okay babe babe I'm just gonna who's
behind are you behind my bike and I
can't move right now hang on
come on now come on now Oh why'd must
you be blocking oh yeah just go and save
the birds rates here are absolutely is
destroyed what what what what ah stop
making my arm be like that
alright I'm what what I'm going for a
journey are we back
I'm just going with glad words no I
really hope I'm going the right way but
you know I don't know anymore
considering my adventure with the bridge
other hand what all got the bridge
I see the bridge yeah he's on the bridge
I was afraid I made it across the bridge
bridge how I don't know I drove right
behind you somehow perfectly what's I
made by jumping over Bob okay it's fair
okay I've got I think I'm on I'm doing
it I think I think I'm am i doing it oh
my god checkered flag oh no really
I got it I got a lap oh you're a wizard
how the [ __ ] I got it
this is terrible it's fine once you can
think of it oh god no I gotta think of
it we talked about the bridge and I
can't seem to bounce my way out I'm
coming back around I'm gonna ram into
you so fast that you'll just be launched
on to the other side okay
well this arm is literally stuck in my
pants what is your my elbow
please help me oh god here we go I miss
you I miss you right I missed I went
right around oh sorry a tit this is my
nightmare
oh my god my arm what is happening my
arm is trying to go to space maybe oh
sweet Jesus send be a good for me oh I'm
flipping over now I'm going in a
direction
now all this just absolutely the wrong
way wait you were in the way we're gonna
launch off the bridge no I'm not yes I
am no I'm not no I'm not yes I am what
direction are we facing is this my front
my back my left my side I don't know man
good luck oh god damn it I didn't get
two feet oh god damn it stop slipping
off the throttle for the love of God
come he frames was it frames time I
think it might be frames time Bob's been
on the bridge for a while I'm off the
bridge now but I mean backwards progress
sup super attached to this okay this is
a nightmare huh maybe you got a grip it
like lower at the base of the shaft
maybe that's really where them I'm not
trying sick my hand into during wheel
and see if I can just lock that
situation down someone I got no problem
with the steering wheel there's a ball
there that I grab on it freaks out it
like freaks my whole card I'm going back
okay
oh wait wait no no got not this early
not I can't be screwing up this early
why is there music there wasn't music
before I don't know there's snow on that
it ended oh okay okay please okay oh god
oh god here we go okay okay
navigating my way out the music's
already over so we're okay I think you
were right mark I think grasping it
lower on the shaft actually does help
yeah I've been uh yeah I agree I concur
oh the steering wheel ball makes my
right arm lose its [ __ ] completely yeah
yes your ball may not be the best way to
go doing it am i doing a reasonable
speed you won't for long man what is
with this bridge in this ball not a good
thing okay well oh where am i where am i
where am i stop stop sup throttle please
for the love of God throttle well I
might what is happening to me ah
oh I'm upside down inside myself
[Music]
okay wheels mistake wheels mistake
hammer through wheel hand went through
wheel hand went right through wheel
whole lot Bob called frame okay mark
still on frame oh no frames just power
over the bridge top come on just what
happened to you arm you were so you're
such a dick alright look lucky look
phone yay no please
2-minute 295 seconds fast over the
bridge Pat whoa it's physically
impossible for me to go over the bridge
I literally do a loop-de-loop with a
turn around the other way a man oh god
curse it's really good for your arm the
way please please God out of the hole
and just oh oh I did it I say I did it
I don't where am I
my wheel is gone my steering wheel is
gone yeah that's what happens to me on
the bridge and suck on that nerd my
wheel I've I've lost the ability to turn
okay I I'm just going my wheels are
pointed it's completely different for
guys by cars possessed by demons can you
can you hit me I apparently can no
longer move think I have any ability to
control my vehicle it is just slam into
me buddy come on just line it up just
come on what I can I got over the bridge
and now I can't move what if my wheels
are pointed left and right I don't know
what you want from me man but it's not a
man hit me at me I'm like that I'm like
in the next corner around if you just
keep going for aren't you are you not
understanding hearing you and I'm
telling you to do better than you are is
no wheel there's no steering wheel I
made a lap
[ __ ] I was so close I didn't finally
bested my nemesis the bridge Oh Bob
please God touch me my wheels have now
decided to stop moving altogether
why am I going that's what's happening
to me I can't I can't move I'm just
gonna keep cranking on the throttle a
little bit great ok on the bridge going
across the bridge I believe everything
on the bridge my arm broke on the bridge
leave me daddy
the bridge really I hadn't seen this on
the bridge but I saw welcome to hell I'm
just gonna sit here me also I pretend
like I'm finishing a lap just I'm doing
flips on the bridge yeah that happens
frames mark how did you get over the
bridge like twice I just kept going and
look I mean those bridge walls it's not
the walls it's any of it yeah it's the
bridge if I get near the bridge I just
[ __ ] splode jeez I was not holding
sounds good yeah I was in the roof of
mark are you blue no I'm red I'm behind
you guys oh I'm RIT where racism erase
them wow I touched you and everything
went wrong okay here we go here we go
bridge bridge bridge you out of my way
oh god damn it damn it
okay this is gonna be fine this time you
[ __ ] have screwed me I don't think
it's our fault man what do you mean it's
not your fault I'm literally up sideways
knows autumn you hit me Oh Great Scott
LOI mark will jingle it yeah help on the
helm I think I was working whatever I'm
doing it's working
okay well we zzzzz on that front
oh wait I said I solved the problem if I
just let go of the steering wheel and
and let my car drive itself over the
bridge with my crazy ass arm can't ruin
it for me okay wait are you gonna go or
not Jesus Christ man I'm doing the best
I can
it's not good enough okay you just let
go oh my god I'm gonna be the winner
this time are you kidding me about
that's the solution all right hey did
you uh find me yeah I did
can you mark me help me nope yeah we
need help I don't know how I'm stuck
[Laughter]
coming back three I knew I should I was
like why would you trust me this is the
fish line no it's not yes it is no it's
not is it
check her things 35 it's better than
wait guys hold it I gotta cross the
bridge all right I'm gonna use my mini
use my newfound my newfound bridge
stratagem and I'm gonna set an even
hotter lap time not if I am here oh my
god my strategy worked again don't shoot
we're gonna go out of it oh jesus take
the wheel hoga okay hon I'm back okay if
you get anywhere close to the bridge it
just all hell breaks loose physics be
damned bones be damned and just [ __ ]
everything oh I got strats now really
really are you joking me yes
look at that [ __ ] huh that's a good lap
that's two in that's two seconds what an
improvement is an example to us all you
need help
oh my god oh my god I just perfect this
is a perfect day would I got over the
bridge now I just need to get my hand
back on the ball right well the right
way again hell yeah oh never mind go the
wrong way again Oh God I grabbed the
ball too early too early little too
early on the man grabbed jumped me fine
it's fine yeah I sure did I sure did eat
my dust Oh God don't I don't hear you my
dog you broke my arm again what did you
do to me crippled the competition that's
what I that's how I do thank God
why is gonna be a good one huh oh god oh
god please no not like this no well I'm
really glad I set that 2-minute time
before this happened to me my steering
wheel is not happy is it there it exists
it exists in like four different states
of existence all at the same actual time
somehow coming in for a really
wibbly-wobbly lap of the most Wibbly lap
I've ever had Hey Wow that time huh oh
my god are you serious yeah apparently a
speed demon look man I don't know my my
wheel was like literally jello the
entire lab this time I don't think
anyone's gonna catch that laughs like be
honest I can't physically do it anymore
I did the the noise of the engine was
like their news
[Music]